In our Japanese Pi curriculum, we
have introduced a system called Daily Grade. This
is before students come to the Japanese class. Students
practice the drills online.
So,
depending on the performance tomorrow, if you're a student who's really prepared perfectly,
then if you come to live without any preparation, 7 to 6
this  Well, it depends on the instructor, but I have that kind of daily
grade. Well
, I think that having that kind of daily grade will also motivate students.
We call that interview test.  It's on the 2nd floor, but I'll do it twice a semester
. The
interviewees are about 5 to 7 minutes. Well, it depends on
the grade, but I ask questions that include the patterns I've studied so far and words.
The teacher is the one
who asks the students to answer. The
interview test is about 5 to 7 minutes,
but if there are 50 students, for example
, it usually ends in another day.  But
depending on the grade, it may take two days.
Ideally, it would be really good to give each student a pede bag, but doing so would
take another two to three days.
So, as a feedback, the best point for students is, for example, 10 points
. Of course, that point is only for me. Of course, that student
made a big mistake in pronunciation.
If so, I personally tell the student